so hilarious Jamaican braid my butt
[Music]
hairs okay there's an Instagram account
I got to tell you guys about it's this
girl and uh her Instagram's called wise
words from Nev from Nev yeah Nev she her
name is Nev yes her name is Nev she
shares her name's not Wise It's not no
okay what's her last name do they say
she shares really really wholesome
content she just tells these like really
like innocent little dad jokes really
wholesome girl for some freaking reason
she has the probably the worst comment
section that exists on people just hate
her I think I heard about this [__] when
you were drawing that out I thought you
say for some reason just the biggest
titties I've ever
seen what kind of milk were they giveing
her yeah can you can you make it like
that here's here's an example a big
titty
story here's an example of just like her
content just so you guys know so here
here it is actually this is a different
girl what did salt say to Pepper during
the
holidays seasonings
greetings she's like a kid and she has
the worst comments ever that's some of
apparently spite isn't an appropriate
word for what motivates you
I don't even know what that was okay so
wait wait wait is she doing like Dad
jokes kind of oh like it's like oneliner
like kid jokes yeah or she'll just like
go like this but they seem like positive
messages every that's tight yeah just
just like I think they should beat her
up I think we should sh out of her what
was that what was that paragraph there's
like a paragraph of like like joke
comment well okay so can I see some
examples I'm going to have Steve read
some of these cuz it seems very like
just innocent lightart so for some for
some weird reason this like this like
running joke happened where there's a
template of comments that people will
always say they'll say something like
hey great joke and then they'll follow
it with the most obscene sentence
possible and there's like thousands of
these and
it's oh like being a 911 deny or
anything like that no that's not that's
not a joke J J it's kind of like that
running
you know I've been seeing on on all
these kid Instagrams like the kids be
like working out or like doing some
Talent or like doing some achievement
and then they'll they'll call them
n-words like they'll be like good job
little nword oh [__] what yeah like
that's like they call kids that like
it's like a running joke so are they
allowed to are the kids allowed to say
so they'll be like a kid that's likeing
they're yeah they no he's like doing
like pull-ups right and he goes day one
out of 50-day challenge right and then
they'll be doing like 10 pull-ups and
then or like they'll be like a kid on
his weight loss journey and there's
always a comment of like you can get it
Lil good job Lil oh I see I see and then
everyone's calling positive
reinforcement but it's like a positive
thing ending with the nword I don't know
why it's likey yeah it's a it's enhanc
it's like an ad boy yeah yeah basically
all right but they say that to anybody
like make my day trying to uh do
self-development to get after it but
especially like teens and kids okay yeah
I don't know positive it's mostly
positive all right you want to read
these so here let's start start mil
let's start
miles I can't wait for these to be taken
out of context put in a documentary I
can't either uh what a funny joke piss
on
me here next one next one oh [__]
hilarious knit my for skin into a
stocking oh jeez what the [__] oh my God
creativity points though wow you really
do have the best zingers put your used
toilet paper in my mouth oh my god
dude holy [__] okay I get it now so
everyone does like the hey you're funny
and then they do something [__] up yes
See's like I got one I got one yeah so
it's just a play on the fact that you're
so wholesome so hilarious Jamaican braid
my butt
hair what the [__] yo they're endless
keep going keep going endless oh my god
well there's a lot of paragraphs and
like there's a lot of like people
putting like her IP address and [__] my
god
dude why that's force feed me your
period blood oh you know what this is
it's like someone taking a megaphone and
then taking it to recess you just kind
of randomly hear what all the kids are a
fact yeah exactly that's a fact so her
um wait one more one more just one more
call call me the nword while you're
writing it [__] dude can we go back to
our content again
yes now we need to do the content yeah
yeah more
content oh my God pull up to every day
I'm Shoveling
one pull that one up my dogs are named
timx and
Rolex they're my watch
dogs get the [__] out of here that's
crazy I wonder how she feels about her
own comments she's like what the [__] is
bro you know this is like great joke I
respect you as a human being that was
why is that one way more funny but like
But like everyone knows that's the joke
so people's comments are just so yes a
guy's like guys don't ruin this
one so the reason I found this page is
because a bunch of people were making
content like a bunch of like white
knight people were like this is going on
and it needs to stop a bunch of like
guys are like don't do this to women
she's so whome how dty like they were
making content about this and it made it
worse cuz more people found it it's like
um it's like the this funny era of like
internet bullying right they just find
these like innocent random people that
they don't even [__] they're not
they're just living life and then
somehow the internet finds them and they
have a running joke there's this one I
[__] love it's like this Barista from
uh
Portland and it's like a girl that
decided to like Venture off and build
her own like coffee trailer right and
then she's kind of like dude they'll be
like out of know they'll be like yo yo
uh thanks lesbian Peter Griffin oh
that's the one I'm thinking of that's oh
no how sad but they're mostly mean
they'll yeah it's like super wholesome
like she's just like making coffee and
whatever and then you'll just see like
big purple nword it's like why it's like
why and it's like it's [__] up cuz
they don't even deserve it they don't
even they're just like living life being
positive they're super wholesome and
then the comments are so [__] up but
this is also one of those anomalies that
like if she can stomach this well her
fan base will be so sick because like
there's also in the in the age old like
there's no such thing as bad press even
with the virality of this ridiculousness
like she's doing like every day
shuffling but she's getting like 160,000
likes on a post she's leading into this
she knows what time she does I think she
does wait 160,000 likes or 160,000 views
she's turning off com yeah she's turning
them off you can't turn them off she has
to turn them off when it gets too bad
wow but you know what I'm saying it's
like that's [__] interactions yeah
those are some imp it's all really bad
he read this one read this one I'm sorry
you're getting harassed your jokes are
cute and you deserve peace and kindness
in your comments please you steal my
kidney and beat me with
it see that's funny bro it's even
funnier the funniest thing I think about
her page is finding people that are like
what the [__] going on in here piss
pee on my meals why would you say that
cuz the interesting thing is it's not
like and I mean I don't want to be like
super generic but it's not like hate
towards her they're almost like really
weird comp it's a bit it's a bit it's a
bit of really weird compliment everybody
wants to yeah I think it's a contrast
cuz it's so innocent
and then you just go in and you see the
worst [__] how many followers does she
have like 400k almost dude guarantee
that's going to be like 450 tomorrow you
know what I mean like read this one
which one read that comment right there
this one this one this one nice joke
white nword I give you the nword pass
say it in your next
video
what that's funny too bad the icon's not
even freaking it's literally there's no
pictures I think there's something
weirdly wholesome about that no pfp some
guys all some guys all haha so funny
queef on my corneas and then he puts his
height
68 what cuz it's a thing where like guys
put their height whenever they comment
so that they get attention it's another
like running joke that's funny oh that's
great the internet is insane dude you're
you're pretty deep in the internet huh
pretty sometimes is deep in the internet
he's on the dark web dude sometimes this
was just making me die because I was
looking through all their stuff we're
like pulling news articles Ryan's like
creating news
articles dude when we're hosting Ryan
must be like over there like falling
asleep he's like good job mainstream
media yeah yeah he's so he's so in the
deep dark web he's just like snoresville
USA he's like this is a snooze so funny
to like imagine these comments come
after such wholesome
[__] what did the mother turkey say to
her disobedient children oh God if your
father could see you right now he'd roll
over in his
gravy oh my God you like that I didn't
like that one and what are the other
comments can I read some it said that's
funny please take a steamy [__] on my
chest what the
[__] what the [__] dude [__] crazy it
says I'm dying of laughter molest me
right now no haha funny feed me your
discharge oh my God oh my goodness
funniest thing I've ever heard pee in my
[Laughter]
nose haha I laughed step on
me yeah it's such a crazy running and
there's thousands of comments like I'm
laughing so much let me smell your twerk
air your
twerk there like people are there's some
pretty original stuff what it feels like
is like there's like a 5-year-old like
piano recital and then across the street
is like The Kill Tony show and they're
just playing at the same time exactly
yeah yeah yeah oh you think though if
you're like um some sort of wholesome
Corporation you're like I don't know if
we could do a brand deal with this
person because the comments will go
crazy here's this's the last comment LOL
so funny queef on my forkin and then let
it out slowly so it makes a balloon
noise oh my God these are wild dude does
she have other channels like YouTube or
Tik Tok I don't think so I think she
just she just does these little like
harmless jokes and wise words from Nev
wow yeah wise words from Nev if you want
to show her some support give her some
love oh no dude don't show her support
but do anything except try to White
night for this cuz that is what makes
that's what caused this that really is
cuz there was so many white night dudes
that were making content about like
preserving her save her yeah or go white
night yeah and it makes it way way worse
so uh
[Music]
enjoy